a tiny bit of trivia that you may or may
not know the year's 2024 and it's almost
going to be one decade of Vin tube here
on YouTube now that's quite a long time
giving you some anime content whether
they be seasonal updates lists that take
you on nostalgic trips or some plain
recommendations so here's the thing I'm
looking to give things a little twist
now so for today's video let's go past
the typical 20 or 10 items on a list
let's try something a little bit
different because today I'll be sharing
my top 30 action anime of this Century
grouping Seasons together as one entity
that means we'll be going from the year
2000 to the present era in a more rapid
fire preview of anime titles than usual
see if you can find something new to
watch ready here we go number 30 is
Doro Doro to me helps epitomize what a
remake should be the base story is
already pretty cool with it being a dark
fantasy with elements of an Underdog
Story and a stand against the world
theme blending together some great
action with a journey of self-discovery
it's a classic that was around where
most of us weren't even born but this
remake from 2019 did more than enough to
bring back this icon into the modern era
the super updated visuals are a given
and the things that make up the heart of
the show the dynamic between our main
Duo and the themes revolving around
morality were all retained it's a pretty
simple story this easy to get into and
newcomers will be more than pleased to
see the spectacular visuals an aesthetic
that's genuinely Japanese and some great
character progression woven in between
visually awesome battles for number 29
we have a certain scientific rail
gum the term spin-off typically signals
mixed reactions with a lot of them
failing to live up to the quality of the
original in the case of rail gun however
it did the opposite and three seasons
later it's easily the piece of media in
the a certain series that's held in the
highest regard it manages is to do it by
simplifying things and crafting multiple
self-contained yet entertaining arcs
featuring a lovable quartet of main
characters and the other citizens of
Academy City things do escalate up a
notch at times but it never seemed to be
trying too hard to be this Grand
spectacular law dump as caused some
people to shy away from the long running
franchise through three seasons rail gun
has managed to maintain its quality and
it makes for a very nice casual watch
one that also has a good share of bright
and awesome moments that make them stand
out at number 28 is my hero
Academia so soon you're probably
thinking you read
mines yeah considering the Legacy my
hero Academia has built and the memories
it's left us with so far I can
understand questions regarding the
relatively low place on this list now
don't get me wrong it's a pretty fun
show that really came in at the right
time when the superhero boom was in full
swing it has a diverse an engaging cast
of characters some uplifting thematic
elements that make it a great start to
Shonen and some genuinely awesome
moments of music that will stay with us
for years to come while it also
generally plays things a bit safe for
2010 standards that isn't such a major
knock on it overall a good St is shown
in and one that looks to be getting more
and more seasons and movies in the
future it's never too late to hop on and
join the eager seasonal fans in the
future number 27 is psychop
pass
psychopath if you to ask me is one of
the anime with the strongest and most
relevant themes when we consider Its
Reflection on reality the dystopian
World being depicted in this action
title seems to inch closer to reality
with each passing day and watching the
implications of that through the lens of
fictional media is something I'm sure
the more analytical of Watchers would
love that's the main selling point of
the series but psychopath has the action
to keep the other types of viewers
wanting more it's got great fight
choreography in the key confrontations
something that has likewise aged like
fine wi the first season of this is
nothing short of amazing and there's
just no way the sequels can live up to
it in my opinion but I think that they
have their own charms and value so don't
hesitate to pick them up after finishing
the first
season my number 26 is something Niche
it's Garden of
Sinners Garden of Sinners is arguably
the toughest anime to watch in the
entire list I don't mean that in a
negative light but this series of movies
is really dialog heavy dealing with
philosophical themes that may prove to
be Meandering to the average anime fan
the way the movies are structured also
adds to that issue but that doesn't mean
that I didn't come out of the movies
feeling satisfied and enlightened about
what depths anime can have it's just
that it's a niche series of films to get
into and understandably so and while the
fighting isn't the main focus of Garden
of Sinners you do see some moments of
Brilliance in the action Department
chiki's always a badass and the
apartment zombie sequence still still
holds up to this day almost two decades
later we got cyber Punk Edge Runners at
number
25 how about a modern video game anime
making its mark on this list eh cyber
Punk Edge Runners is pretty much Peak
video game anime if I had to quickly
recall things off the top of my head it
wasted no time getting me hooked and it
really showcased the strength of the
Cyber Punk show and the implications of
a world where Humanity and Technology
intersect the world is great and it's an
anime that's full of heart one that's
full of intensity and emotion too it's a
surprise hit from 2022 that I honestly
didn't expect to be this good but here
we are Studio trigger did it again we
have more recent anime on the list with
Heavenly delusion at number
24 I have to say this show caught me off
guard entering its season I never
expected that much of it definitely not
to the point of it being one of Spring's
best hitss all eyes were on OKO Demon
Slayer and hell's Paradise but Heavenly
delusion ended up being a big winner
That season this sci-fi mystery provided
something different from the usual fair
and it managed to maintain its dark and
ominous atmosphere all the way to the
end Heavenly delusion definitely isn't
something I consider a Gateway anime
it's got some elements that disqualify
it from being a show I can easily
recommend to anyone but the
post-apocalyptic backdrop and how it
Bridges two story lines two plots full
of intrigue together is something that
I'll always credit for my enjoyment of
the
[Music]
show and if we're talking about under
the radar how about Blades of the
Guardians at number
23 Chinese anime has rapidly been
stepping up its game recently and if you
want proof of that look no further than
Blades of the Guardians from this past
year given to us by the people who
helped bring us King's Avatar this anime
has everything you'd want from a period
show a well- written story with eye
popping fights that don't shy away from
showing some violence and a lot of
fleshed out characters for you to follow
it's pretty simple in execution and
doesn't exactly try to be something
unique but with its Excellence on the
production side of things it just
doesn't have to be if you like
historical anime in any form you love
this and you'll find it very easy to
binge this anime due to its really
interesting story at the end of the day
that's all that
[Applause]
matters let's not leave that time period
because our next entry number 22 is
Demon
[Music]
Slayer to further hammer down the point
the execution is what really matters
here we have Demon Slayer Demon Slayer
at its core is a simple story but I
think that's really where its strength
lies a story that's easy to follow with
some lovable characters that the
audience can attach themselves to and
care about and some insane fight
animation and effects the formula to
craft a winner and a record-breaking
medeor Empire I'd say Demon Slayer rode
those highes and easily took over the
anime World in 2019 while also possibly
showing the blueprint to success for an
action show in the modern era credit
where credit is due while Demon Slayer
may have its share of critics when it
comes to what it's supposed to do well
like craft a simple yet very engaging
story to entertain battle shown and fans
and Demon Slayer really really excels
number 21 is helling
Ultimate if you were to ask someone from
the 2000s what the definition of edgy
stylish anime looks like and look no
further than helling ultimate the 2000s
was an ERA where the dark reddish
aesthetic as well as the non-nonsense
badass Demon Slayer protagonist was cool
and every teenage boy's dream throwing
in the unbridled Madness the violence
and that don't give a damn attitude and
you have a show that encapsulates what
makes that era so cool to its credit
Hing ultimate is a show that actually
has some pretty sensible themes woven
into it but we all know people back then
didn't watch it for those most of them
wanted the cool edgy stuff and they
wanted to Relish in the Carnage of Epic
Battles the mature content for big boys
that can only be possible in the world
of anime Hing ultimate was the perfect
source of that
fix at the rank 20 Mark we have a look
at mushoku
tensei as always a word I use to
describe mushoku tensei is Pioneer it
helped create the isaki we know today
with it showing its influence in the
genre to this day at its core mushoku
tensei is a story of exploration and
self-growth it's also a bit harder to
find a PE for the series when it comes
to World building and the anime is one
of the adaptations that had so much care
put into it it was one of the best
adapted light novels out there and signs
are pointing to more anime content to
come granted it's GED its fair share of
controversy so it's not a title that
I'll readily recommend to anyone that
doesn't change the fact that in terms of
production and Legacy it's one of the
key foundational series out there number
19 on the list is chainsaw
man chainsaw man really burst onto the
scene didn't it the hype was off the
charts even before it aired and it
wasn't like anything I've seen recently
then the actual product came out and I
did have my doubts after watching it
I'll say it pretty much deserved most of
the excitement surrounding it as a
supposed spectacle chainsaw man is
nothing short of impressive the fights
are insanely cool and all but let's not
forget the characters who are charming
and show an element of self-awareness
with the anime fan culture at large I
give you this though compared to more
typical action anime chainsaw man isn't
something easy for the Everyman Anime
Watcher to get into it's pretty dark and
has themes and humor that people used to
watching safer things like Demon Slayer
May deem questionable still evaluating
it as just an anime and a visual
production is pretty much everything an
action anime fan would want in the
modern world something that I felt was
grossly underrated however is my number
18 anime summertime
[Music]
render summertime render is an
interesting case it started out leaning
heavily on the mystery aspect but at the
halfway point it transitioned into an
exciting action anime that made such
great use of the time reset concept that
seasoned anime Watchers may be familiar
with at this point contrary to the
common sentiment I see online it's
actually the second half that made me
more engaged where the question shifted
from making sense of the shadows and the
murders to finding a way to solve the
puzzle and overcome a seemingly
unbeatable foe capable of using our
protagonist's greatest strengths against
them summertime render is an amazing
Thriller through and through it utilizes
the time reset mechanic in a way to keep
Stakes high and it's a show that keeps
you on your toes thinking alongside the
characters with regards to its Mysteries
best of all it's a contained narrative
that neatly wraps everything up in its
over 20 episode
rum number 17 is bongo stray
dogs talk about a series that just keeps
getting better early Bongo stray dogs is
a joy to watch piecing together
Mysteries exciting fights and powers and
literary references provided me with
something enjoyable to pass the time
with however as the stakes gradually got
higher and higher in the future Seasons
I could confidently say that we had a
winner on our hands here the first parts
of the series may just drag on a little
bit but they don't even give you the
full picture and it's a series that you
learn to appreciate the longer you stick
with it I personally like how the fights
are well thought out I guess it helps
that this series is categorized the S
end hence the more mature themes the
darker backdrop and the more methodical
action sequences it's overall a well
produced show that can be your favorite
if it hit hits the right notes for 16 we
have
[Applause]
parasite here's another mature action
anime parasite Blends a philosophical
and environmentalist theme with a high
octane action series that boasts a great
main Duo Dynamic the combination really
works as some will hop on for the brutal
action sequences and the heart pounding
suspense in fights While others will
stay for the surprisingly
thought-provoking messages that the
anime tries to tell us the
characterization for both the
protagonist and the antagonist are also
on point and they help make this series
a memorable one for me parasite is one
of the best things that 2014 gave us
it's too bad that it got overshadowed by
a lot of bangers airing alongside it
still fans of sci-fi horror shouldn't
miss this like summertime render it also
Paces itself nicely and wraps things up
neatly so you won't come out of this
feeling lacking here we are at the
halfway point hit that like button while
you're at it to help the channel out
with the YouTube algorithm we still got
15 anime for you so stay tuned for the
second half of the list margi comes in
at number
[Music]
15 mari's an anime that I didn't really
look at at first but ended up being one
of my favorite shows around the
mid-2010s taking inspiration from the
Arabian Night stories with its overall
setting margi crafts a really
interesting world that parallels our own
throwing some daring Adventures
well-rounded characters whose individual
Journeys we follow a cool power system
and some political Intrigue and you have
one of the surpris hits of its era it
was really a complete package and the
second season was even better than the
first one in a lot of ways unfortunately
you have to read the Manga to know the
rest of the story from that point
onwards on the other hand at least they
got the peak of the series animated when
it comes to different point of view
characters nothing does it better than
[Music]
bakano a well-renowned classic from the
late 20000s Bano primes itself in its
unique way of telling his story
different events different characters
more seemingly unrelated but eventually
converging into one big narrative you
unravel once you're done with the show
it's truly unconventional and it's
something that not a lot of people can
appreciate at first but I honestly think
it's genius with how it opens up
numerous ways of looking at events and
characters all the while it also
successfully mixes suspense comedy and a
whole lot of action much like summertime
render Bano is a show that keeps your
mind working and figuring things out
it's definitely more lighthearted than
the former but Bano also has a lot of
moments filled with drama and
tension
[Music]
our number 13 anime however seems to go
all in on Comedy this is
[Music]
Gintama Gintama over the years has
become synonymous with parody off the
rails comedy and a lot of wild
exaggerated Expressions I things that
Gintama has pretty much owned if you to
ask any anime fan in the 2000s however
it would be a disservice if we're going
to reduce the series to its signature
brand of Comedy even though being king
of comedy is its claim to fame beyond
the laughs beyond the crazy moments as
well we have one of the most dramatic
and epic Tales revolving around a bygone
era in Japan a lot of genuinely
heart-wrenching events and Goosebump
inducing scenes of Triumph await those
who have the patience to plow through
the hundreds of episodes now the journey
may be long but it's oh so rewarding
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure is at number
12 where to start with JoJo one of the
most creative battle anime out there
that's dropped footprints on Meme
culture in the anime sphere maybe we can
start with the battles and powers that
simply ooze creativity how does the
anime just not seem to take itself
seriously and go up and Beyond with
giving us some some of the most
over-the-top sequences in anime they're
making things look really cool while
doing so it takes a genius to pull that
off but thankfully araki is the man for
the job with so many parts available for
watching you'll have more than enough of
your JoJo fix there's no better time to
start getting into the hype train of
this generational Adventure than the
[Music]
present one punch man is number 11 on
the list
if you want to see what mad house was
putting out in its peak years then look
no further than this anime that swept
all over the airwaves in 2015 one punch
man setup and the underlying joke are
simple you have a protagonist so strong
he easily defeats everything in one
punch it's appar of the whole
overpowered hero thing but watching a
couple of episodes is all you need to
tell that there's way more to it you can
Feast on the the spectacular visuals
pretty much on par with eupo table or
you could find yourself caught up with a
charming cast of characters who you'll
easily get attached to it truly Nails
the formula for an enjoyable parody
while being more than competent in the
production side of things the second
season didn't quite capture the magic
but I still find the series overall to
be a very fun watch that's more than the
sum of its parts we start our March to
the top 10 with mob psycho
100 you think one pun man season 1's
animation is great wait till you see the
unmatched visuals that mob psycho has
made its claim to fame but putting that
aside I'll just say that the show is
just plain fun to watch the plot's quite
simple but with how endearing the
characters and their respective arcs are
this is an anime you just can't put down
it's exciting it's definitely the best
amongst the Charming supernatural
character dramas in the world of anime
the cool thing about mob psycho its
succeeding Seasons more than held the
line even improving in some aspects that
means even more thrilling battles more
emotional Stakes down the line and of
course Peak art and animation bleach
comes in at number nine on the
list few anime in the 2000s can come
close to this Supernatural battle Series
in terms of exuding a certain Aura of Co
it's not overly edgy or anything like
that but there really is a more mature
bite with how bleach's characters world
and storyline are there's a distinct
teenage Rebel energy that makes it my
favorite amongst the mainstream Shen
back in the day if we're just talking
visuals in the overall feel of the
characters bleach is cool plain and
simple and it rode that wave into
becoming one of the most influential
anime in the 2000s there may be some
mixed opinions regarding the series as a
whole some manga criticisms which I
concede to even as a fan however that
makes its recent run for Thousand Year
blood War all the more exciting thousand
year blood War has done such an
excellent job in filling in some lacking
details in the manga's final Arc as well
as presenting its key moments in
glorious fashion whether it be in the
sound or visual
departments k
iing Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood is
here at number
[Music]
eight you know there's not a lot of
anime I can give the distinction of
being the complete package one which can
really appeal to the people who enjoy
their action at Adventure but also
appealing to those who prefer smarter
and more philosophical shows with strong
writing and a tight narrative a lot of
anime show promise but to masterfully
hit the right notes in both categories
they're few and far between Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood falls into this
category an epic adventure some of the
best written characters in all of anime
a fair balance of action and
introspection and a story that doesn't
lose momentum at all Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood has it all I won't
call it the absolute best anime ever bar
none but the hype is definitely in the
right place for the most part much of
the praise for FMA has has been directed
at Brotherhood and rightfully so still I
wouldn't Overlook the first season the
original FMA also has its fair share of
moment at Lucky Seven we have one
[Music]
piece
head with two and 1 half decades under
its belt one piece has continued
captivating fans worldwide even in the
year 2024 just how does it keep doing
that with infinite possibilities one
thing I'll always love about one piece
is just how many stories it can tell
with its seemingly Limitless world a
world that's filled with all sorts of
characters and societies even through
all of these years the feeling of being
wide-eyed and excited at the prospect of
an adventure is always there for one
piece it's hard to encapsulate
everything that makes one piece great in
just a paragraph or so but I would place
the adventure aspect first and the
Charming character second oh and for for
fans who can't get enough of Demon
Slayer and it sheer production value
modern one piece has a lot of fights
near that level
too number six is
[Music]
Naruto a now this could be a
controversial take because narut itself
was one of the more polarizing shows in
the 2000s despite its popularity to me
the criticisms don't really take away
from the fact that the show was that
important in anime's mainstream
popularity and at its core it
legitimately had a great Underdog Story
to Tell it has an interesting World a
Litany of memorable fights and moments
and some genuinely heartfelt and
wholesome themes perfect for both
younger and older fans alike it's not
the perfect anime by any means far from
it but I really enjoyed it and it's one
of the pillars of anime that introduce
the medium to a whole generation the
long journey even after you take away
the notoriously long fillers is well
worth it top five on the list Is Vinland
[Music]
Saga I think highly of Vinland Saga the
same is true even in its second season
where the action has taken a backseat I
just think that it makes Vinland Saga
one of the most complete anime out there
being able to give us an epic and mature
adventure of Revenge as well as long
moments of reflection that I feel modern
anime just don't get enough of
historical action anime has never been
this cool while being legitimately
educational before and I'm all for that
I put villin Saga as my anime of the
year in 2019 and it doesn't take a lot
to see why it's a really holistic
experience of what anime can be it's a
great gateway to anyone who wants to see
the best of action anime number four is
Jujutsu
Kaizen such a hot upster already
managing to take the Reigns to be in my
opinion the fourth best action anime in
the century being released recently has
a lot to do with how Jiu-Jitsu Kaizen
has seemingly learned from its
predecessors and improved in a lot of
areas Supernatural action has never
looked this awesome before and the
second season has been a big turning
point in the series as a whole each
episode of the Shibuya AR had me on the
edge of my seat but I feel that the big
moments needed time to just breathe the
first part of season 2 however was a
different story and it's arguably even
better I know I know recency biased and
all of that but still that doesn't
change the fact that jiujitsu Kaizen has
in some areas perfected the formula of
the genre that's filled with memorable
characters and insane fights you're
missing out as an action anime fan if
you're not watching this now starting
our countdown to the top three is Fate
Zero The Fate series really had a
stronghold in the anime world around the
2010s I love a whole lot of them whether
it be the movies ubw the fgo titles and
such but if I were to recommend just one
to watch it would definitely be zero
this prequel to the mainline fat day
night story is a modern Masterpiece with
impeccable plot progression and a
gripping tail that heavily revolves
around morality not to mention you have
awesome fight scattered all over with
breathtaking displays of power through
the character's Noble fantasms FAS zero
really is the chronological starting
point if you want to get into Fates day
night but it's also the best one amongst
them I love ubw and the heavens feel
movies to death but Zero's really where
it's at if you've got only one go at a
fate
title Hunter Hunter the 2011 version is
in second
place this really is one of my favorite
anime of all time Hunter Hunter is the
show that has it all you still got the
magic of the '90s version with its
captivating plot well written characters
and creative powers and battles but this
time add in more modern presentation
techniques and you've got one of the
best remakes possible Hunter Hunter has
aged wonderfully in the new era if you
want Adventure if you want some
imaginative fights if you want awesome
character writing Hunter Hunter has it
all the hype is more than Justified for
this show it's not your typical show in
anime and it's well worth your time even
if you've already seen a lot of anime
this will truly provide you with an epic
experience that you won't
forget
saving the best for last we have Attack
on Titan at number
one what else could be at the very top
of this list none other than possibly
the most influential action anime of
this Century sure the big jump shown in
had their time to shine in the 2000s but
I really don't think anything can
compare in sheer impact Attack on Titan
took the World by storm and he just had
to be be there to even comprehend how
big it was it had the perfect
ingredients for the aformentioned storm
with a gripping storyline a lack of the
usual anime tropes fan service and plot
armor and oblique and cynical Outlook
which made it perfect for the worldwide
audience it also had one hell of a
character development as an anime
showing that it can be more than just
action survival anime in its decade long
run truly one of the most memorable hits
in the decade and a landmark title for
this
generation
and there you have it the top 30 action
anime as far as this century is
concerned well what about your picks
make sure to share them down in the
comments below don't hesitate to let me
know some of the shows that you think
got snubbed in this particular list
because I'm sure that there's probably
tons of them once again thank you for
watching and I wish you a great day I'll
be seeing you sooner rather than later
with the next video on this channel